we have a north las vegas police officer
in the spotlight tonight we're talking
about officer nicholas quintana says
compassion and his faith pushed him to
do something really unimaginable
christian casa is joining us now live in
studio with a story that you'll only see
here on channel 8. that's right guys
well we're talking about officer nicolas
quintana he has been with the department
for four years and has responded to many
calls over his career now he tells me
about one call in specific that really
touched his heart and how his home is
now overflowing with love
i'm a regular guy you know
who happened
you know god called me to their incident
north las vegas police officer nicholas
quintana says he can't comprehend why he
felt so passionate during a homicide
call he responded to in january but he's
glad he did stirred my heart to all of
this was
well if i'm being entirely honest so i
definitely empathize with him my father
was
was killed by a family member of mine
officer quintana says he was on his
dinner break january 14 when a call came
in about a murder on osaka pearl street
in north las vegas when he arrived he
learned a man had been shot and a woman
arrested he also saw five children in
the midst of chaos the youngest the
six-year-old she had said no you know
but i love daddy that definitely that's
what i said you know it was choked up
and walked away and that's when those
those those callings started that night
officer quintana spoke to his wife about
the children how do you spark a
conversation in the midst of the most
traumatic thing that they will probably
ever go through how do you do that days
later a meeting was set up with the
children through child protective
services so i look at the kids and i say
well you know the whole reason why we're
here is not just you know because i want
to check up on you the whole reason why
i'm here is because i would like to
receive you guys into our home we'd like
to take you out of the system you know
out of out of child haven
are you guys okay with that the oldest
one the 17 year old
she specifically asked you you want all
of us and i said yes all of you every
single one of you those five yeses
kicked off the adoption process for
quintana and his wife who had been
trying to have children for years their
small home is overflowing with lots of
emotions but mostly love definitely
testing my faith
to be very specific with you and it is a
little stressful i'd be lying if i said
it wasn't if it wasn't stressful but
overall
you know i'd like to say that you know
things are things are
better and good
lots of smiles there all right officer
quindena says it will take a while for
the adoptions for the adoption process
to go through now the nevada police
union will they are helping out with
donations as well as beds and dressers
for the children and guys as we wrapped
up the interview with the officer well
he tells me that basically i mean he his
hope
his hope and his wife's hope was just
that all these kids just grow up
together stay together yeah just amazing
amazing just an incredibly big-hearted
gesture and and commitment by that
couple what about the extended family of
the kids why did they not go with them
so the officer tells me that the family
they all had relatives outside of las
vegas were talking about outside of
nevada and even in other countries and
again their focus was that they just
wanted these kids to just grow up uh
together not be separated within the
system it's incredible yeah good for
them big heart